hello in this video we'll talk about the
clinical benefits of intermittent
fasting if you are wondering what is
intermittent fasting so let me tell you
it's a time restricted feeding pattern
when you have a time where you don't eat
and you have a time where you eat so
there is a alteration between feeding
and a fasting window
there are different ways by which
intermittent fasting can be performed
and the most popular ones are 18 is to
six intermittent fasting where you fast
for 18 hours and feed for six hours time
window
and the next is alternate day fasting
where you switch between a feeding and a
fasting day and keep it up for the rest
of the week
now all of these paradigms has their own
benefits and pros
in a different video i'll be discussing
that anyway you can check out my basic
video on intermediate fasting by
clicking on the i button
in this video we'll focus on the
clinical benefits of the intermittent
fasting we'll talk about how
intermittent fasting is helping to
reduce weight it can be beneficial for
increasing the lifespan we would also
talk about how intermittent fasting can
be
good for our cardiac health
later on we will talk about how it helps
in stress resistance
how it helps us to improve
our cognition ability lastly how it
helps in disease management like
diabetes management
so
all these clinical benefits are based on
the review article published in
new england journal of medicine where
professor mark p matson
summarize all these benefits and he's
from john hopkins university so don't
forget to check out this article which
is provided in the description
let's start with
how intermittent fasting helps with
weight loss and improves cardiac health
so these days obesity is a big problem
our sedentary lifestyle lack of exercise
work life stress and
food with refined sugar and eating too
much of processed food can lead to these
obesity related problems and obesity
comes with the cost of dyslipidemia or
high risk of cardiac diseases
so
intermittent fasting can be really
beneficial let me tell you how
intermittent fasting is now proven to
reduce weight and it helps in obesity
management
there are clinical studies which suggest
intermittent fasting can also improve
the lipid profile if it is followed
properly
imagine you are fasting
under these circumstances if your body
needs energy it has to
act on the energy reserves
so in our body in the adipose cells
there is triglyceride which works like
an energy reserve during fasting
triglyceride would be broken down into
fatty acid which is transferred into the
liver and liver utilize fatty acids and
oxidize them to generate atp which is
the energy
so in order to generate energy and keep
our body functional
fat reserves are utilized so obviously
the result is fat depletion and we would
be
seeing that our
fat reserves are gone so weight loss is
prominent
next thing is how intermittent fasting
can be beneficial for increasing the
life span
now pre-clinical studies in rats has
shown that if the rats are
in a diet form where they undergo
alternate day feeding that means
alternate day fasting paradigm
then their overall survival percentage
increases several fold
similar evidence comes from macaques so
if you
feed these macaques with
some kind of caloric restriction
paradigm or five is to two intermediate
fasting or alternative fasting it turns
out their
their lifespan has increased
so exactly how lifespan has increased by
intermediate fasting
is still a topic of debate and intense
research but the outcome is pretty
amazing
now
question is whether these kind of
preclinical studies are at all valid for
human
now it turns out if we look at several
tribal populations such as okinawa in
sentinels in the okinawa island
munza tribe in pakistan
and
another tribe in the andes mountain
mountain we will find some striking
results
all of these tribes has an average
lifespan greater than 100 years
and one of the ritual is common in all
of these tribe that is fasting and
intense exercise
that in turns tells us that
the preclinical data that we obtain from
mouse or rodents
might be true in human as well now human
clinical trials are underway and this is
an important aspect to understand how
intermittent fasting can help us in a
healthy aging
now one study suggests that there are
several types of intermediate fasting
which has different outcomes for example
when a group of hundred women who are
all obese or overweight was uh put on a
diet of intermittent fasting for six
months period in one group they followed
five is to do intermittent fasting and
in
one group they follow daily caloric
restriction it turns out both of these
groups show
reduction in weight
they have shown significant weight loss
and decrease in waist circumference but
the group which has undergone five is to
two intermittent fasting
they show a higher insulin sensitivity
also
they have written lean mass while uh
reducing the weight so that's pretty
amazing and there are many other
clinical trials which shows intermediate
fasting is quite beneficial so all these
links would be provided in the
description now next stuff is how
intermittent fasting can be
beneficial for our cognition and the
functioning of our brain
it turns out intermittent fasting can
help you to work better focus better and
think better
that might be pretty confusing to you
right but hear me out
so
there are recent studies which shows
that intermittent fasting helps in
memory consolidation and it has improved
cognitive aspects
so how does that happen
think about when we are evolving
so our food available availability was a
kind of uh minimal someday our ancestors
get food and someday they have no food
so they have to
hunt right
so in this process
they have to be really focused while
hunting
otherwise they could be also
a prey instead of a predator right so it
turns out fasting
has
created some kind of advantages in them
such that they can focus better in terms
of collection of food and that's how we
evolved so far
now what really happens during fasting
that helps our cognitive benefit
when we are
fasting there are certain products that
are generated in the liver known as
ketone bodies such as acetoacetate
acetone beta hydroxybutyrate
many of these ketone bodies has
effects on our brain and these effects
are neuromodulatory let me break it down
for you
so ketone bodies are like reserve fuel
so
when we fast in an intermittent fasting
paradigm our brain runs with these
ketone bodies but but when we are
feeding our brain utilize glucose for
energy production so there is a
ketogenic to glucogenic switch in these
intermittent fasting paradigm and this
metabolic switch is really beneficial
while we are on keto
then these beta hydroxy butyrate
which is generated at libitum while we
are fasting let's say we are fasting for
12 or 16 hours beta hydroxybutyrate
levels would go up so beta
hydroxybutyrate can increase one
neurotropic factor known as bdnf
bdnf is shown to be
very beneficial for brain it helps to
create new neuronal connection it also
helps to
helps in neurogenesis that means we are
making improved connection and making
more neurons in our brain and that kind
of explains how intermittent fasting can
helps our cognitive abilities
moreover it
we know right now that our neuronal
circuits need to have a steady state
firing rate an increase in steady state
firing rate or decrease in steady-state
firing rate could be detrimental for us
and an activity sensor might sense these
excitability and whenever excitability
goes beyond or below a steady state
level it can readjust
the steady state firing rate
and it turns out these ketone bodies can
one can be one of these metabolic
sensors
it does recent research shows that beta
hydroxybutyrate
can
inhibit glutamatergic signaling which is
a
neurotransmitter signaling
responsible for excite excitability in
the nervous system
it turns out beta hydroxybutyrate
positively regulate kcnq potassium
channels which leads to
uh
which leads to reduction of the neuronal
activity so overall modulation of the
neuronal activity is mediated by
the
ketone bodies which are produced during
intermittent fasting or a prolonged
time of fasting
now these evidences are not really new
actually these evidences are found in
greek mythology
so epileptic scissors are one kind of
manifestation of electrical uh
electrical uh
disparity in the brain
so epilepsy is a severe disease these
days and it was there in ancient greece
as well
so ancient greek people thought epilepsy
as a demonic position
so in order to recover them they kind of
locked them inside a holy temple and it
turns out after few days when or when
this particular individual comes out he
is kind of normal
now we understand when he was locked in
the shrine
he was fasting and fasting leads to
several keto ketone bodies which might
have given kind of a kind of benefits in
these epileptic uncontrollable
excitability
that is how
overall
ketone body generation during
intermittent fasting is super beneficial
for our brain
now let's talk about
how intermittent fasting can helps us to
deal with stress more efficiently it
turns out when we give our body stress
by doing exercise we generate a little
bit amount of ross
or when we fasting we also give our body
some amount of stress
so this stress allows our body to
recycle things better let me explain you
how
so prolonged fasting induces a
particular cellular process known as
autophagy
in autophagy
cell cellular organelles and
proteins which are non-functional gets
recycled
and all the raw materials
are utilized to build up new organelles
or new proteins
so this recycle procedure or renovation
procedure really helps our body to cope
up with stress
let's say we need a functional enzyme
under a stressful situation
so in order to make this enzyme we need
the raw materials which are the amino
acids and peptides so all of these can
come from our diet
but
during fasting we don't have a dietary
input
of these amino acids
then how our body
cope up with this stress and how does
our body make these functional enzymes
then our body focuses more on recycling
method
body up regulates the methodology of
autophagy that means it kind of looks
for non-functional protein and recycle
them to take the spare parts and build
up functional protein
in this process not only the body is
generating functional protein which is
important to fight stress but also it is
recycling all the faulty and the garbage
protein and this is kind of like a
molecular garbage clearing mechanism
this is how our body fights if you don't
understand this integrate details of
molecular
biology then let me tell you in a
simpler example let's say you have a
house and in your locality there is
severe rain and storm all the time so
obviously your house gets a minute
damage every time it rains and you have
a nice damage repairing system you
always call the
mechanics to repair the damage in your
house
so obviously renovation happens very
frequently in your area
so you are now better prepared
in severe disaster like a tornado or
hurricane
so next time there is a damage you can
efficiently recover
or
efficiently renovate your house because
you are trained to do so similarly when
we are we train our body with small
amount of stress every day
then our body learns how to cope up with
stress more efficiently and that's what
happens during intermittent fasting
so we evolved so far but there was a big
problem with our evolution
our lifestyle has become more sedentary
and we consume excess amount of calories
because we have a lot of money to buy
food right now we don't have to hunt for
food
now with a combination of excess food
and sedentary lifestyle
we are now obese as a global population
and this comes with the cost of
dysregulated
lipid profile increased triglyceride and
overall increased risk of your cardiac
failure
now
let's talk about how
intermittent fasting could be good for
diabetes control so in case of in case
of intermittent fasting it has been
shown
that
cells
upregulate the glucose transporters and
thereby allows glucose to enter the cell
so this is how intermediate fasting
could be pretty beneficial for diabetes
management where the glucose is actually
trapped in the blood circulation and not
able to enter any cell types
so now this video kind of summarize all
the health benefits which are clinically
proven
so if you like to uh contribute to my
channel you can do that by patreon or
let's say do that by
bimupi app if you're an indian viewer if
you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe do let me know your know your
uh impression in the comment and lastly
you can take my courses in academy by
using my code mp10 you can get it in
person discount thank you